muss ich will dass sie nicht
bremen in norddeutschland team süd macht
einen stadtrundgang
es gibt viel zu entdecken besonders
bekannt ist die stadt für ihr
historisches rathaus und für das märchen
der bremer stadtmusikanten bremen ist
aber auch eine bunte internationale
stadt sucht den interkulturellen garten
in bremen tenever und seinen
vorsitzenden abdelhafid katar schon
stehen die drei vor dem ersten problem
wo genau ist der stadtteil tenever und
wie kommt man dort hin was das team
nicht weiß ihr ziel bremen tenever ist
auch sozialer brennpunkt der in den
meisten großstädten oft ähnlich aussieht
viele hochhäuser und wenig grün hier
soll es einen garten geben tatsächlich
wie eine grüne oase liegt der
interkulturelle garten zwischen den
hochhäusern
aber wo ist abdel hafidh
teil 1 der aufgabe ist schon mal
geschafft jetzt folgt teil 2 stellt
samen kugeln für eure eigene guerilla
gardening aktion her aber zuerst zeigt
abdelhafid ihnen den garten
auf der anderen seite könnt ihr sehen zu
hochhäuser damit aufgewachsen leben
circa 90 prozent ausländer mit ungefähr
80 nationen wo jetzt hier sein leben
die zukunft von bremen gitter meisten
kinder in mittlerweile gibt es viele
interkulturelle gärten in deutschland
sie unterscheiden sich deutlich von
typischen kleingärten
wir haben hier keine satzung keine
großen vorschriften und zwar die leute
können ihre eigene ideen präsentieren
ohne sie angst haben müssen dass nach
vorschrift sein muss
sie zufälligerweise pflanzen sammeln
einmal rein
ich denke hier ging männlichen wie mein
vater ist im krank und macht als
vermisst hat wurde er als folge haben
nach honig und im prinzip ja sozusagen
das sein leben ist auch gut für die die
beschreibung auch sehr wundert ihr im
garten einfach keine hektischen bewegen
wenn sie jetzt anfangen hektische
bewegungen zu machen dann ist es ein
bisschen gefährlich
in der zwischenzeit mal den trotz aller
angst vor bienen der honig schmeckt und
samen für die aufgabe bekommen die drei
auch aber wie werden aus pflanzensamen
kugeln ahmed muss weiter hat aber hilfe
organisiert ein guerilla gärtner seine
bewegung hat sich zum ziel gesetzt
großstädte zu begrünen machen
das ist ein hier bei uns noch wenig
übrig kite das war nicht so schlimm ich
kann mich ins gefängnis habe ich mich
gern geld dafür bezahlen
das macht eric nicole und ein moderner
aber keine angst das trägt zur
entwicklung der der natur das ist egal
was ist normal dass seine perspektive
einige stunden später die drei finden in
der abenddämmerung einen idealen ort zum
begrünen
nun ist es zeit für den guerilla gärtner
zu verschwinden neue punktestand 3 zu 3
jetzt aber schnell weg
berlin
was sie nicht